[Music]  who are you looking forward to seeing  here tonight i've been kind of wowed at  all the stars that are walking around  partying  [Music]  and she's from new york like me and i  love her what is it about that song that  has us all just moving i don't know you  can't with me if you wanted to these  expensive these is red bottoms these are  bloody shoes it just makes you feel like  like i am here yeah like don't mess with  me and the thing i love about her and i  was telling dj khaled this  you've got to give props to someone who  brings themselves from nothing in  nowhere yeah  she's from new york she's she's a hard  working girl her hustle is strong and i  think she's amazing absolutely i love  that song she doesn't become a party if  it really is cardi b we love you